With eight narratively complex seasons under
its belt, American Horror Story has left us
with a number of doozies to puzzle over.
With that in mind, here's a look at this long-running
hit anthology's biggest unanswered questions
and there's more than a few.
Spoilers ahead!
Murder House, American Horror Story's first
season, set the foundation for the series
by introducing us to the Montgomery House,
an infamous mansion in Los Angeles with a
disturbingly high death count and a history
of violence that goes all the way back to
its first owners in 1922: Dr. Charles Montgomery
played by Matt Ross and his wife Nora played
by Lily Rabe.
Dr. Montgomery, a surgeon to all of Hollywood's
finest in the 1920s, built the Victorian home
for his wife.
He never fails to remind her, and it always
fails to impress her.
"I built you this house, exactly the way you
wanted it."
"And how many servants do we have?
Two?"
When they fell on hard times, Nora decided
that Charles should start offering abortions
out of the basement.
"No one will ever know…
But we do require payment up front."
After an abortion went very wrong, Charles
was exposed and the father of the baby dismembered
the Montgomery's newborn in retaliation.
"Charles…?
Oh my god."
Crazed with grief, Charles sewed the baby
back together and reanimated it.
The child was bloodthirsty, and Nora ended
up killing all three of them.
Their ghosts continue to haunt the house…
along with anyone else who died there.
Were these terrible events enough to shatter
a psychic veil and create the house where
the eventual Antichrist would be conceived
and born?
Or was there something more?
This vital question to the entire AHS arc
has never been answered.
If people kept going missing after booking
a stay at a particular hotel, you'd think
the place would be positively crawling with
law enforcement…
But no, not at the Hotel Cortez.
"I need a room, one night."
"$150."
"Says here $30."
"That's out of date."
Like Murder House, the hotel racks up an enormous
body count due to the evil energy of the place,
yet people keep booking stays at the Cortez…
and when they die terribly and violently within
its walls, nobody seems to come looking for
them there.
Does this have something to do with an enchantment
on the site laid by the vampire Countess,
played by Lady Gaga?
She's been in the fashion industry for decades,
yet nobody seems bothered that she doesn't
age.
Did she cast a glamour over herself as well
as the hotel?
Is this somehow related to Gaga's role as
the original Supreme Scathach in Roanoke ? Something
definitely seems to be up.
After all, the Robichaux witches even know
Queenie is there, and yet nobody goes looking
for her.
That may be due to some sort of black magic.
And consider this.
When Will Drake is killed at the hotel, his
son Lachlan is also staying at the hotel but
we never see Lachlan again.
Did the Countess turn him into one of the
ravaging vampire children?
Is he still there and is he still alive?
We just don't know.
We will… probably never know, will we?
American Horror Story: Asylum is packed to
the brim with bizarre occurrences.
We meet a supposed Anne Frank who lived.
We get acquainted with the serial killer Bloody
Face.
We witness the evildoing of a Nazi doctor,
who continues his vile medical experiments
on patients.
But one of the plot threads that still leaves
us scratching our heads involves Kit Walker
played by Evan Peters and his abduction by
aliens.
After his supposed abduction and return, his
wife also disappears.
Authorities arrest Kit under suspicion of
being serial rapist and murderer Bloody Face.
Kit is locked away in Briarcliff Asylum, and
nobody believes his alien abduction story.
"Your story about little green men - no, that
won't do here."
"They weren't human."
He suffers terribly for crimes he didn't commit.
We never get a definitive answer about the
aliens in American Horror Story, but Ryan
Murphy discussed the puzzling plotline with
Entertainment Weekly, explaining that:
"For me, [aliens] were always an obvious metaphor
for God.
It fit very easily into the world of a Catholic
sanitarium asylum.
[...] It was also about science versus faith
so it made sense to me."
Still, we'd like to know what these malignant
extraterrestrials were up to.
Then again, aliens are notorious for their
wild ways.
American Horror Story: Roanoke features Uber
driver Rhett Snow played by actor Billy Snow
and he seems to be the only working driver
in the area.
He gives Cricket a ride, almost killing Flora
by accident in the process.
"You know, I just prayed to god everyone was
alright."
He also gives Dylan a ride back to Mott Manor,
evidently totally fine with the fact that
the guy is wearing a Pig Man mask.
Rhett shares the same last name as the fashionista
witch Myrtle Snow, and his first name is shared
by Rhett Butler in Gone With the Wind, one
of Clark Gable's most famous roles.
Could Rhett Snow be a member of Myrtle's extended
family?
Giving him an old-fashioned name would be
such a Myrtle thing to do.
Are other members the Snow family similarly
driven by glamour and glitz… and were they
eager to name Rhett after a pop culture figure
from days of yore?
If so, is Rhett possibly a warlock like his
witch relative?
Will he feature in a future season?
We probably wouldn't have seen him so many
times without a reason… but what is that
reason?
In a horrifying reveal during American Horror
Story: Murder House, we discover that the
latex-clad Rubber Man is, in fact, the ghost
of Tate Langdon, and he's the one who forced
himself upon Vivien, impregnating her with
Satan.
So who is the second Rubber Man in Apocalypse?
It doesn't seem to be Michael, because he's
walking the halls and interviewing people
in Outpost 3 around the time Rubber Man is
doing his sexy business.
Then again, Rubber Man clearly gets around.
Gallant and the second Rubber Man have sex,
and later on, Gallant is startled when Michael
claims it wasn't him in the rubber suit.
"You're pathetic."
When Gallant sees the Rubber Man again, he
stabs him in a fit of rage.
But beneath the mask, it's not a man at all.
No, it's Gallant's grandmother Bubbles, played
by the legendary Joan Collins!
It's a pretty eventful night, all told.
Was the second Rubber Man even real, or was
he merely a hallucination?
It's ironic that Evan Peters played the original
Rubber Man in Murder House, only to be on
the receiving end of his assault in Apocalypse.
Time really is a flat circle, huh?
American Horror Story: Apocalypse spends a
great deal of time and attention on Emily
and Timothy, the star-crossed lovers in the
end times living in Outpost 3.
When they're captured and taken underground,
they're both told that they were selected
for their excellent genes.
"The elite.
The worthy.
Those chosen to survive."
Their forbidden love only draws them closer
together.
By the end of Apocalypse and after the time
reset, we learn Emily has given birth to the
next Antichrist.
Why were they included in the apocalypse bunker?
Did someone know Emily and Timothy were destined
to sire an Antichrist in the event of a time
spell being cast to destroy young Michael
Langdon?
Was Outpost 3 hoping for another devil child
to rule the end of the world?
Or does this mean that the forces that are
trying to foster the Antichrist are well aware
of multiple timelines?
Also, Emily and Timothy are both human and
Satan must be conceived with human and spirit,
like Michael was.
So, is one of them not who they say they are?
Could one of them have been under an identity
spell all along?
So many questions.
American Horror Story: Hotel ended with a
number of pressing questions that were never
resolved.
For example, what happened to the Countess'
disfigured vampire baby Bartholemew after
she was killed on the property and became
one of its ghosts?
What was the significance of the recurring
2:25 hour?
Oh, and we have some questions about that
gang of real-life serial killers.
Each year on Halloween, they somehow manage
to visit James March, the man who built the
Hotel Cortez.
As you no doubt recall, Richard Ramirez, Aileen
Wuornos, John Wayne Gacy, Jeffrey Dahmer,
and a masked Zodiac killer all attend a dinner
party in celebration of Devil's Night.
"I don't get you, man.
The real fun starts after you get caught.
Don't you know that?"
Each year they drink absinthe and murder together
with glee.
But none of these serial killers happened
to die in the Hotel Cortez, obviously.
So how do they get there?
And where are they all chillaxing the rest
of the year?
In the world of American Horror Story, ghosts
tend to stay where they were killed… but
not these prolific murderers.
What allows these serial killers to go and
join James March at the Cortez for one night
a year?
Does he have some witchy powers that are never
discussed?
Or is there something else behind their ability
to roam about freely?
Can other ghosts do this?
Fingers crossed for a future season that clears
up these unanswered questions from American
Horror Story's fifth season.
Theories, anyone?
In American Horror Story: Coven, Evan Peters
plays Kyle Spencer, the president of a college
fraternity.
When Madison and Zoe go to a raging party,
Madison is drugged and sexually assaulted
by a bunch of frat guys until Kyle intervenes.
Madison is so furious about the attack, she
uses her powers to flip over the frat boys'
bus, killing a great many of them and also
killing poor sweet Kyle.
Feeling guilty about Kyle's death, Madison
and Zoe visit the morgue and decide to resurrect
him … but there's a problem: The boys were
all left in pieces.
Madison finds Kyle's head and then picks choice
body parts from the various dead frat boys…
in order to create what we'll respectfully
call "Franken-Kyle."
The spell doesn't seem to work at first, but
when it does, Kyle clearly isn't the same
kind-hearted guy he was before.
He eventually regains his strength and ability
to speak, and by the end of the season, he
becomes becomes the Miss Robichaux Academy's
butler and protector as Spalding had been.
We return to Robichaux in American Horror
Story: Apocalypse, but there's no sign of
Kyle at all.
Evan Peters is all over Apocalypse in fact,
he plays four different roles throughout the
season: Mr. Gallant, James Patrick March,
Tate Langdon, and Jeff Pfister.
So it's really rather odd that Franken-Kyle
doesn't make a single appearance throughout
the season.
What happened to him?
Did he die again?
Or could Ryan Murphy be saving him for a future
season?
Time will tell.
What was the witch Mallory's real identity
and why was she so powerful?
We know that Queenie's lineage goes all the
way back to the Salem witch trials.
Misty Dawn comes from a long line of swamp
witches.
Supreme Fiona and her daughter Cordelia are
both white witch royalty, as are Madison Montgomery
and Zoe.
But we know virtually nothing about Mallory,
or her past when we meet her as a personal
assistant in American Horror Story: Apocalypse.
"Are the Kardashians filming out there?"
She was functioning under an identity-cloaking
spell, so it makes sense that she didn't know
who or what she was, yet it seems nobody else
knew either.
Apocalypse never really addresses her identity
or lineage at all, which is surprising: People
with her level of immense power tend to rise
from well-known bloodlines.
This begs the question: Is Mallory even a
witch at all?
We need Ryan Murphy to circle back around
to this one.
We learn in American Horror Story: Coven that
there can be only one Supreme at a time, and
when her powers and health begin to weaken
it means another Supreme is on the rise.
Fiona had to die in order for her daughter
Cordelia to ascend, just as Cordelia has to
die for Mallory to take her powers.
But in American Horror Story: Roanoke, many
of the terrible events are set in motion by
the wood witch Scathach, who they say is the
original Supreme.
But how can that be if there's only one at
a time?
Is she a ghost Supreme?
Does being the first give her exceptional
powers?
We demand answers!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about American
Horror Story are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.